Cristina Fernández No dio la definición
que muchos esperaban de ella En este
acto no dijo quien debería componer para
ella la fórmula presidencial para las
elecciones de este año del frente de
todos la coalición peronista de gobierno
de la que ella es vicepresidenta y
además de la que es la principal líder
por eso su opinión su posición se ve
como algo fundamental en este contexto
para definir eventuales candidaturas
pues no dio ningún nombre Ella viene
insistiendo en que no es ella quien
Debería ser la candidata a pesar de que
se volvieron a escuchar en la Plaza de
Mayo cantos pidiéndole por parte de sus
seguidores que ella vuelva a presentarse
a la candidatura algo que ella ha
insistido como digo en que no quiere
hacer pero bueno no estuvo esta
definición de quién Debería ser el
candidato a la presidencia según ella lo
que sí estuvo En este acto conmemorativo
por los 20 años de la llegada del
gobierno a la presidencia de Néstor
kirchner su fallecido marido lo que sí
hubo digo
fueron críticas al gobierno de Mauricio
macri que estuvo en el poder entre 2015
y 2019 y una muy fuerte defensa y
reivindicación de los gobiernos de
Néstor kirchner y los gobiernos de
Cristina Fernández que lo sucedió en el
poder de ella misma y también algunos
comentarios con bemoles respecto al
gobierno actual de Alberto Fernández del
que dijo que En definitiva según ella es
un mejor gobierno del que habría sido si
era de otro signo político además llamó
a la militancia a su militancia a hacer
un fuerte trabajo de base tal vez de
Cara a estas elecciones para fortalecer
las chances de sus eventuales candidatos
o para convertirse en una fuerte
oposición si terminan perdiendo las
elecciones de este 2023